oktober und november 2018 hat genau zu
ihr größtes manöver seit 2002 abgehalten
man übt er den bündnisfall also
gemeinsame verteidigung im falle eines
militärischen angriffs auf ein oder
mehrere nato-mitglieder
damit wurden auch wieder erinnerungen an
die zeit des kalten krieges geweckt
heute in vechta kompakt das nato-manöver
trading st im rückblick
[Musik]
an der großübung haben alle 29
nato-staaten sowie finnland und schweden
teilgenommen
es wurde zu lande zur see und in der
luft geübt der raum erstreckte sich über
das zentrale und nördlichen norwegen
sowie umliegende gebiete des
nordatlantiks einschließlich island
teile der ostsee sowie den luftraum von
finnland und schweden
man hielt aber reichlich abstand zur
russischen grenze um zwischenfälle zu
vermeiden
in der ersten phase ging es um die
abwehr eines angriffs nördlicher kräfte
in der zweiten phase erfolgte ein
gegenangriff internationale beobachter
und mehr als 200 journalisten waren
eingeladen um das geschehen zu verfolgen
russland schickte zwei experten aus
österreich war mit zwei offizieren im
rahmen der osze vereinbarungen vertreten
der aufwand für tri den stürmer
beachtlich mehr als 51.000 soldaten 274
hubschrauber und flugzeuge
61 schiffe und u boote sowie etwa 7300
fahrzeuge waren im einsatz
und so zum vergleich erst im september
hatte russland laut eigenen angaben
300.000 man 1000 flugzeuge 80 schiffe
und 36.000 fahrzeuge in der übung
rostock aufgeboten
das manöver verfolgte zwei strategische
ziele zum einen die dokumentation der
verteidigungsbereitschaft und des
inneren zusammenhalts zum anderen die
demonstration einer glaubhaften
abschreckung
es sollte eine potenzielle gegner ist
russland gemeint das signal gesendet
werden dass der preis zu hoch sei
ein nato land anzugreifen operativ ging
es um die fähigkeit zur planung und
vorbereitung in dieser größenordnung
überprüfung und verbesserung der
verlegung sweg eid verbesserung der
zusammenarbeit aller teilnehmer und um
die überprüfung der einsatzbereitschaft
der schnellen nato-angriff kraft zur
bewertung der befehlshaber im nato
kommando in neapel bezeichnete dass man
darüber als großen erfolg
man sehe aber auch
verbesserungspotenziale so sei die
abstimmung mit einigen internationalen
partnern noch auszubauen
außerdem könnte die verlegung von
truppen in andere bündnisstaaten rascher
erfolgen
es wurde betont dass die allianz die
starke bindung zwischen europa und
nordamerika und ihre
innovationsfähigkeit demonstriert habe
dies erfolge durch den einsatz von
mikrofonen und robotik bis hin zum 3d
druck der generaldirektor des eu
militärs bezeichnete die übung als
chance zur verbesserung der
zusammenarbeit von eu staaten und nato
deutschland zeigte sich zufrieden weil
es den test zur führung der schnell nato
eingreiftruppe die berlin 2009 10
übernimmt bestanden hat einige
zusätzliche anmerkungen mit dem üben von
kollektiver verteidigung kehrt die nato
zu ihrem gründungsgedanken und ihrer
kernaufgabe zurück dieser trend hat mit
der annexion der krim 2014 durch
russland begonnen und setzt sich nun
verstärkt wird die zweite kernaufgabe
mitwirkung am internationalen krisen
management verliert damit weiter an
bedeutung
diese entwicklung hatte schon in den
letzten jahren aufgrund der
enttäuschungen und misserfolge in
afghanistan im irak und an anderen orten
eingesetzt
51.000 soldaten und 274 luftfahrzeuge
klingen zwar beeindruckend das ist aber
angesichts von rund 2 millionen soldaten
in europa nicht sonderlich viel
die beteiligung schwedens und finnlands
wiederum verdeutlicht dass sich diese
staaten infolge der veränderten
bedrohungslage bereits weit fest möglich
der nato angenähert haben ein kurzes
resümee das nato-manöver trader in
tanker wurde ohne nennenswerte
zwischenfälle abgeschlossen erste lehren
wurden gezogen
ob die strategischen zielsetzungen
erreicht werden konnten bleibt
allerdings offen so stellt sich vor
allem die frage welche stärke die nato
tatsächlich in einem verteidigungsfall
aufbringen könnte und ob damit eine
abschreckende wirkung zu erzielen ist